hello and welcome to this Bloomberg
Businessweek Town Hall on mental health
and the time of coated 19 there's a
national pandemic and it's not the one
you think I'm low ever the editor of
Bloomberg Businessweek shameless plug
joining me is my colleague Cynthia Koons
a senior reporter for Bloomberg News
who's one of the very best health
journalists around Cynthia thanks for
joining me thanks for having me Joel
this is going to be a great opportunity
we're hoping to hear from all of you in
the live audience about the things that
you want to learn about mental health
right now ways to access care issues
you're dealing with when you need care
feel free to treat this as an open forum
for you to ask whatever you need to
really get to the heart of what's going
on here and how people can access care
in this time of social isolation that's
right
Cynthia you've written a ton about
mental health for the magazine over the
last year including a recent article
about the challenges facing in the
system because of the corona virus which
obviously helped inspire today's
discussion I want to know who want you
to know I also put on a caller for the
first time and a couple weeks from
working at home I've been wearing
t-shirt so it's nice to actually you
know feel like I'm I'm doing real work
today
we also have some great guests that will
be joining us and I'm really excited to
engage with them on this important topic
because they're they're just really
really a big names and this mental
health space first of all we're gonna
have dr. Mimi Winberg of Brightside
where she's a chief medical officer also
dr. Neal Leibowitz of talk space he's
the chief medical officer there and we
also have dr. Ken Duckworth and chief
medical officer for the National
Alliance on Mental Health Amit Mental
Illness excuse me and dr. Christine
Moochie a chief medical officer for the
American Foundation for Suicide
Prevention this is the first time we've
been doing a town-hall like this so
please just bear with us if we encounter
any technical difficulties but in
general we're going to divide the
program in just three 20-minute sessions
in the first block we'll talk about how
the telehealth platforms are meeting
this moment with our first two deaths
then we'll change gears and switch to
how people are being affected by the
mental health crisis with our other two
guests and then we'll bring everybody
back together for the last 20 minutes
where we will be able to ask
bunch of your questions that happens to
be one of the best features to this
format it's basically interactive if you
have a question you'd like to ask any of
our guests please just type it into the
comments and we'll do our very best to
field as many as we can when we get to
that point in the program now without
further ado let's get started with our
first two guests dr. Mimi Winberg and
dr. Neil Leibovitz Mimi Neil thank you
so much for joining us thank you for
having me thanks so much for having
excited to talk about this important
issue with both of you telehealth in
three weeks
telemedicine has gone from being
something that people probably weren't
using so suddenly it is the only game in
town right and I'm curious what kind of
spike in demand you're seeing meal for
you first and how is your your platform
rising to meet this moment we've seen an
incredibly large unfortunates spike in
demand it's been at this point over 65
percent and it's people coming looking
for therapy we've seen demand in a lot
of different ways though so in addition
to people seeking therapy we've done
some work to open some free facebook
groups Instagram where for people who
need a little bit of a lighter touch and
really get help and we've seen huge
demand numbering in the thousands there
as well so overall it's really been a
flood and Nene how about for you at
right-back yeah I think I can echo some
of those some of those sentiments we've
seen about a 50% increase in our first
quarter which you know was largely
reflected in the month of March as this
started to escalate and last week was
probably our busiest week ever I think
as sort of the immediate needs of people
are getting met like making sure they
have a good place to shelter and taking
care of food now people are beginning to
start to address mental health concerns
that are arising as a result of this
crisis and so we've seen a big spike in
the last week as well which is normal
right here right here I am self
isolating with my family and anxieties
everything feels like something that
just feels like it's settling in in a
way that you know most of us
probably aren't used to like there's a
certain amount of social interaction
where you do and now we're sort of being
deprived of that what are sort of the
first things that people are reaching
out and asking for help about well I
think I'm not sure if you direct that
question to me but I think one of the
things that's really clear is that our
brains sort of how long as predictive
engines you know we're constantly
scanning the environment thinking about
our past and trying to predict what the
future is going to look like and we do
this unconsciously we do this all the
time about everything in our life human
right yeah that is that's how our brains
work it's how we function in the world
and right now that process has gotten up
ended because we're not able to make the
usual predictions that we can about the
future everything feels uncertain
everything from what's going to happen
to next week you know next week with our
jobs the economy - are we going to be
healthy - you know is our usual part
going to be open to will our grocery
store be open so it's you know it's
everything is sort of uncertain right
now and what that does is it creates a
lot of uncertainty and then a lot of
fear and then ultimately a lot of
anxiety so what would you say to people
who are dealing with some of this
anxiety that is sort of part and parcel
of living through this when is it time
to seek help versus when is that okay
we're all living in crisis and this is
pretty normal way to feel yeah Oh like
you said where you're gonna get your
groceries from next week so as mental
health professionals and a psychiatrist
we we do this based on really people's
symptoms and the severity of those
symptoms and I would say one of them and
also the notion of how much those
symptoms are interfering with our daily
lives so interfering with our ability to
get through our social functions and our
work I think the best way to find out if
you really need help at this point is
just to take an assessment if you go to
our landing page at bright side comm you
can take a free assessment and we'll
give you your results right away that
will help put in perspective how much
your symptoms are interfering right now
and how severe they are so we can
actually scale the amount of mild
moderate severe level and then make
recommend
patience based on that but we tend as
medical professionals to think about
these things in terms of symptoms and
then interference with our ability to
function in life Neal I know that you at
talk space offered free therapy for
frontline but frontline medical
providers who are working with Puli
patients to a very intense demands on
their their work and personal life at
the moment
wondering what the utilization of that
has been thus far in the response from
that community in terms of their need
for mental health so as you mentioned
it's been really a wonderful experience
just emotionally we started with a
thousand months we opened it up to the
therapists on our network we donated an
additional 300 months which we matched
and then Michael Phelps recently donated
an additional 500 months bringing it to
2,100 we've been burning through those
months health providers have been coming
to us I don't have the exact numbers as
to what we've utilized but we're
probably about halfway there in terms of
using that amount but what's been
actually very amazing and interesting
has been some health care providers have
come to us and as they've been going
through the match to come in to therapy
have said you know I'd rather just pay
for it and leave my month for someone
else which has been amazing to just sort
of even for the health care group in the
first responder suffering through this
even seeing that compassion at that
point has been overwhelming I saw some
[Music]
non-medical hospital personnel or having
more is some sense more anxiety even
than the hospital the medical personnel
I think there are a lot of people in the
ecosystem that you think about working
in hospitals and really close to it all
first it one of the things about medical
professionals is that this is sort of
what we're trained to do right you think
of firefighters kind of going into the
fire without without necessarily
experiencing that anxiety each time they
have to do in and I think medical
professionals are trained to function in
this kind of crisis
it doesn't mean it doesn't take a toll
on them but they are prepared
psychologically to deal with these kinds
of things I'm not and to be totally
honest right like I mean this is a
moment that I think a lot of people are
wrestling with maybe maybe feelings that
they had that they're not used to
feeling with or their partners and
that's actually one of the questions
that I want that came from the audience
that I wanted to share with you but a
viewer Gotham asks how do I support my
anxious partner in uncertain times like
these that you know dealing with anxiety
issues that you know maybe become more
pronounced in this moment and I'd also
just like to encourage everybody to ask
more questions and we'll do our best to
surface them either in these chats or at
the end so that's actually a great
question and we've seen a secondary wave
of people coming in looking for help
with relationships it's now hard I'm in
an apartment it's hard with family and
kids and a lot of really those pressures
trying to do all the things we do in the
daily life so I think one of the things
that we're all doing is we're beating
ourselves up and as weeks go by and even
the health care workers and everyone is
we're putting in an ordinate of stress
and we're trying to be I guess our best
selves and this is a time where it's
really hard to do things the way we want
it's hard to not get upset at people
it's hard to not get angry at your kids
it's hard to focus as much as we want at
work I'd like to say I'm as efficient as
I am always I'm probably not I'm
definitely not and I think a lot of
people are going through that and I
think we need to try to figure out a how
to give ourselves a bit of a break and
understand that we're not always who we
want to be right now we're trying to be
most of who we want to be but especially
that short temper or sometimes feeling a
need to kind of withdraw it can be very
natural and also cutting those around us
some slack whether it's your kids and
maybe they need to watch a little more
TV because they need an outlet maybe you
need to have let your significant other
take a little bit of a time or listen to
them in a different
way and there's no regiment for this
there's no real roadmap but I think we
need to accept that they are struggling
and that we are struggling and to try to
balance that me I'd like to kind of ask
you a similar question when you're
engaging with maybe a first-time client
like what are some exercises that you
offer them so that they have a toolbox
that they would maybe wouldn't otherwise
have yeah yeah well I think it's really
helpful to try to first just identify
what you're feeling so I ask people to
try to name their emotion the emotion
that they're experiencing and that while
it sounds very simple can really help
focus your thoughts and calm you down
and kind of at least put a name to what
you're feeling and then by naming it you
can categorize it and put it into a
bucket and then on that subject of
categorizing it's really helpful to
think about worries that you can do
something about versus worries that you
can't do anything about so I encourage
people to sort of hit the play button
and take things to their logical
conclusion so if you have a worry well
what does that worry imply and then
where might that go and if there are
things you can do to reassure yourself
or to feel more prepared then absolutely
take those measures but if it comes up
to a dead end where there's really
nothing you can do about the worry
that's when it's more helpful to do a
breathing exercise or maybe dissipate
the worry with some exercise some yoga
go for a walk take a bath do you know do
another activity that might relax you
because it's a worry that's actually out
of your control so I had one question
that I got from someone who tweeted it
to me and I just wanted to throw it out
there for anyone watching you can tweet
us questions live at hashtag BW
townhall's though as your questions have
you questions feel free to throw them at
us live one question was from a provider
a mental health care provider and asking
specifically for advice for the mental
health care providers working in private
practice perhaps this is how to adapt
their practice perhaps it's how to cope
but they were asking for advice for
themselves for their own sort of mental
health
period yeah it's a tough time to be a
mental health provider because you're
absorbing the worries of so many people
you know I know I've felt it personally
I've been seeing about 14 patients a day
and everybody has their own version of
anxiety McGarry Wow yeah thank you you
feel like a sponge kind of absorbing
people's worries so I think it is really
important to have some self care
practices to set boundaries between your
work and your own personal life because
so many of us are working from home
right now that that physical boundary
might not exist
maybe you're stepping into an office
space but me maybe not maybe you're
working for your dining room table that
can also blend you know anxieties from
work anxieties bleed into personal life
so I think starting each day with the
ritual maybe that's the meditation or
some yoga or going for a walk before and
after seeing patients can help with some
boundaries on the day and not let let
things seep in as much again self care
practices staying tuned in to what you
yourself are feeling staying informed
and altruism in itself has been shown to
be an incredibly effective coping
strategy and you know Neil alluded to
this that I think one of the things as
providers that we're seeing right now is
this outpouring of altruism and we are
thinking about the planet we are
thinking about other humans on the
planet in a way that we haven't in a
long time and that itself is I think
quite therapeutic and I know Brightside
is just very honored to be able to serve
people in this time because it's it's
it's just at the time I think when we
feel more connected to other people I
totally I feel that way as well
and you know one of the things that
relates to that that I'm curious is and
you guys as telemedicine professionals
and especially in a resident how long of
a moment do you think that this could
become for your business model right is
it a flash in the pan or do you think
that this could be something that you
know changes how we engage with
healthcare professionals I think this is
a real inflection point you know I think
telemedicine has been an obvious choice
for mental health for so long I might
self have been practicing telepsychiatry
for years and years and you know was
very proud to launch our telepsychiatry
as well as our teletherapy program at
bright side and this is a tailwind right
now for for telemedicine because it's
not just a lifestyle choice or a
convenience and it is all of those
things right now our lives might
actually depend on it and so I think
this is going to make us re-evaluate the
way we communicate in general in all
areas of our life but I think
particularly in medicine it just raises
the fundamental notion of do you need an
in-person visit for your complaint and
if you don't why would you go to an
in-person visit right now right we gotta
be a question from a viewer which is a
very interesting one and for maybe dr.
leave its you want to take this one but
this person is asking at what point is
it worth going to see someone presumably
from 50 feet away but at least go a
visit or when do you start to recognize
that their symptoms of anxiety and
depression that they're expressing to
you are more serious that you need to
actually sort of try to intervene in a
way that you might normally if you were
not explicitly split should circum
trying to sort of process the question
and is the question when point you
should see when what point in terms of
if someone is expressing their concerns
or their anxiety or their depression to
you at what point are the things you're
hearing critical enough for you to
intervene the question is whether or not
to see them but I think more in a
broader sense when when to intervene
when to say okay these things that
you're expressing to me make it make me
think you should actually seek help and
in what manner so a lot of people coming
into treatment come because someone else
told them to and for men and this is
more anecdotal a lot of men come in and
I asked why do you here and they say my
wife told me to come so it's not
uncommon for someone to see the signs
before you see the signs yourself so
that's actually
wonderful question and once and I'm
gonna go back to what dr. wins burg
mentioned which is when it's really
starting to take a toll that it's
affecting what you're doing in a day are
you getting up late for work we should
all be on time for work right now but
yet for a lot of people that's a
struggle is that a struggle are you
someone who is really spending your
weekend in bed and that's not like you
times have changed a little bit but we
need to adapt someone and if there is a
difficulty adapting and you haven't left
your house in a week right and you're
seeing someone who like to be outdoors
they haven't left they haven't gone for
a walk those are the signs that tend to
make me concern and should make someone
else concerned obviously if it reaches a
higher threshold where there's
discussion of suicide if there's sort of
that hopelessness that really can be
foreboding and shows some of those risks
that would also be important and I think
taking an assessment or sending that
person to take some sort of assessment
whether it's on a website free there are
plenty of free tools available as well
really be beneficial so I have another
question and this comes from shreya sand
I think it's a really important one
because you know one benefit that I have
in the middle of all this is that I can
actually focus on my job and my work
which actually gives me some sense of
purpose almost in the middle of all this
but a viewer Shreyas asks how can I do
with anxiety after losing my job due to
coronavirus right and that feels so
immediate because for any of us who are
working if we're not rooted in the same
reality that someone who just lost their
job because of these circumstances Oh me
me or Dutch meanie what advice do you
have for them yeah I mean this is what I
was referring to before of I think we
have you know much in the way that that
there are many people walking around
with asymptomatic or pre-symptomatic
Cova dry now I think there are a lot of
people that have a pre-symptomatic
mental health condition in that the
groundwork is being laid for a lot of
mental health issues by a lot of jobs
of meaning in life and we don't know how
this is going to manifest in the coming
weeks and months we don't know what toll
this will take so it is a very difficult
situation right now if you've lost your
work or don't have the same sense of
meaning that you had prior to this or if
you're worried about how you're gonna
pay for your groceries two weeks from
now you know these are very real
problems and these as this plays itself
out we may see some emerging mental
health issues that we don't know are
there right now and and and I think this
is something that the the mental health
system has to be ready to address in the
coming in the coming weeks and months
risk applied risk for depressive
disorders things that go beyond the
immediate anxiety of the situation we're
dealing with I would would back to yours
a very specific question of how to
manage this kind of anxiety I think
again bring it back to the things that
you can control right now so take stock
of your day think about you know how you
can focus on things that do bring
meaning spending time with family may be
a good one to do right now making sure
to try to eat healthy and get some fresh
air and exercise each day one one way or
another if you can and you know focus on
the basics if that's all that you can
control right now even if you're not
working I'll actually mention we're
gonna have time for one more question on
this session and then we're gonna
transition to our next section session
and then both Mimi and you will come
back for our last one Cynthia do you
want to do the honors of our question
yeah I just wanted to get a quick over a
quick sense of how you guys are meeting
the demand given availability of mental
health providers has been a chronic
issue in the u.s. now we're faced with a
surge in demands all over the country
and I just was wondering how how it's
working in terms of scaling up and
getting the rider to the availability
providers can be huge
yeah well without compromising care -
yeah much in the way that we've seen a
big surge in demand from patients we've
also at Brightside seen a big surge in
demand from
providers so providers really want the
opportunity to practice telemedicine
right now they know we have our ducks in
a row and have a really you know an
excellent platform that takes into
account all kinds of factors that but
many health groups do not have right now
so providers are flocking to us as well
as patients which is wonderful because
we're able to meet this surgeon demand
and we're act where we're fast tracking
providers right now in hiring hiring
them quickly and getting them trained up
you know in anticipation of an even
greater surge in the coming month or two
and so that's been really really helpful
to see people coming out for that
likewise on our end with the surgeon
demand and fast tracking we've also been
obviously paying close attention to any
licensure changes whether temporary is a
way to meet demand in various parts of
the country as they come and then the
other important piece to that question
was how do we keep providers from
burning out themselves and I think many
answered that very well
the other pieces we've opened up slack
groups not selectively some zoom groups
for our providers to talk to each other
it can be very isolating being a mental
health professional in absorbing it is
very hard and having giving them an
outlet to talk to each other whether
it's commiserating or sharing clinical
experiences have been very valuable to
decrease that burning dr. Neal Lewis dr.
Mimi Winberg I just want to say thank
you to both of you oh we're gonna
transition to our second session now and
you'll come back through our third and
again just thank you for joining us
right now thank you
thanks so much okay so we're gonna
transition to our second session and
we're gonna bring in dr. Kim Duckworth
and dr. Christine Mookie a Cynthia how
are you thinking about the second
session well both Ken and Christine work
at big national organizations and one
thing when I thought about where your
organization spent and the spectrum was
we started out with the people who are
offering the home-based care for people
who may be able to self-identify their
symptoms and seek care appropriate care
through that Avenue but there are a lot
of Americans
symptoms might be more severe and they
might be looking at a situation where
telehealth might not do everything for
them or there may be other circumstances
or more critical situations where people
need care that is really difficult to
get right now so I thought we could
start there as one particular Avenue
Christina I'd love to hear about the
demand or the work you guys are doing at
the suicide foundation to understand a
little bit about sort of what you're
hearing from the community and what sort
of need is coming there and how this is
impacting people with more severe forms
of major depressive disorder or the
other conditions that can lead people to
become suicidal sure thank you so much
at the American Foundation for Suicide
Prevention we are we fund research we do
advocacy on the hill and we have a
grassroots network across all 50 states
and made up primarily of thousands of
people who have been personally touched
either by mental health struggle suicide
loss or suicidal attempt and living
through that and so it represents a very
very diverse group of people who are
partnering with their local communities
and listening to the need out there and
so what we're hearing a lot right now is
an interest in mental health like never
before the topic of mental health is top
of mind alongside this infectious
disease pandemic and that is a good
thing this is in a way kind of a
historical moment that I think accrues
to the culture change that's been
happening over many years that that is
even now in the national dialogue and
across communities in that way you know
the way that we've been taking an
approach is really to stay focused as
much as possible very upstream on social
connectivity on shoring up your own and
your loved ones and your colleague and
co-workers mental health and resilience
and feeling a sense of even connection
and solidarity with even though our
shared experiences can be quite diverse
as you've already
touched on some people are losing their
job other people are working at home
while their kids are spooling at home so
but that yeah right right many of us
that's me
same here so you know I think there are
many different opportunities going on
but the the effective strategies those
basics that we just heard about how to
keep our physical and our mental health
as optimized as possible whether or not
we have a mental health condition that
all of that self care proactive strategy
applies to all of us that's mainly what
we've been focused on can I'm really
curious from your perspective you know
there might be people who are wrestling
with serious mental health issues that
preceded this current moment and now
they're socially less socially isolated
how do you go about reaching those
people in this time of need well the
National Alliance on Mental Illness is
of course the largest grassroots
organization of people with mental
health phoner abilities and their
families in the country and we're proud
to partner with AF SP and many of the
other groups that are here to be in
service to this population one UNAM e's
expression is you are never alone and
this has never been more true as
virtually everyone now is experiencing
some version of anxiety and fear
so Nami has 650 affiliates across the
nation and so what I encourage people to
do if you have a pre-existing
relationship with Nami contact your
state affiliate or local affiliate there
are groups of people who will have
family members who are quite ill and
vulnerable there are individuals who
problem-solve how to get 90 days of meds
out of their Medicaid there are people
who've done therapy through a
traditional phone not televisions many
Medicaid's across the nation are
covering old-school flip phone sessions
which don't have much of a research base
but it's something if you're in
inpatient care right this is a
tremendous challenge because
historically psychiatric facilities are
not well set up for infection control
what
is that planning ahead mean for when you
leave and what is the safest place for
you to go
so Nami has a helpline one eight hundred
nine five Oh Nami it has experienced a
tremendous boom in people trying to
problem-solve because while this is a
common problem to us all many of these
things are very individual you have
panic disorder it's going to generate a
different problem set for you than if
you live with schizophrenia and you are
in a homeless shelter and so the Nami
helpline is a group of forty peers or
staffed up to help people then of course
there's also the not the national crisis
text line which is 741 741 another great
resource Thank You dr. McKee I have a
question from one of our viewers Liza
who asks what mental health resources
are there from the government and how
can our public officials be doing more
to support us right now those are great
great questions
well Samsa is our substance abuse and
mental health government agency
so between Samsa the CDC's priority on
mental health and suicide prevention as
well as the National Institutes of
Health and Mental Health and all of the
Institute's that that are related NIDA
and and and I Triple Eight which have to
do with substance use and alcohol use
all of those government entities offer
resources for example Samsa has one of
the best treatment finder links if
somebody is not sure how to go about
looking for a mental health provider
during this time or somebody struggling
with substance abuse issues
those would be Samsa and NIDA would be
wonderful resources for that and
actually on our AFS P website for people
who are looking for treatment and
support we have our our top treatment
finder links there you know it's it's
been alluded to already with this this
rise in the need to be able to access
health service both
medical and mental health services using
other modalities than in-person visits
right now and I will applaud Congress
for making the federal changes necessary
to the legislation that have loosened
the restrictions and allowed for
telehealth services to go much wider and
broader than ever before in our history
we would urge our government not to
revert back to old times as soon as the
coronavirus crisis is over because I
think if the analysis is done what we'll
see is that having access to effective
mental health services across the board
during normal periods let alone during a
period of public health crisis like now
equates to so many savings and so many
positive impacts on physical health
measures on workplace productivity our
economy all of this inter relates and so
those are some of the things that are
top of mind and I'm probably missing a
whole bunch actually it's a good
question thank you well just for people
who are coming in late I just wanted to
say welcome to this Bloomberg
Businessweek town hall on mental health
dr. moody I have a follow-up question
that one of our viewers Ethan and it's
one that I actually am deeply interested
in as well which is you know we've seen
suicide numbers over the last decade and
change continued to rise it is there is
this a moment because of what we're
dealing with that that we're seeing any
sort of additional rise in any sort of
suicide numbers because of these
circumstances
that is a really important question and
one that I'm happy to address because we
don't want there to be an assumption
about suicide risk right now because in
fact what the scientific literature
tells us is that it's it's incredibly
complicated but that in previous periods
of natural disaster wartime and
pandemics there have been mixed findings
at both suicide rates going down in some
instances thought to be related to the
natural
sort of societal coming together and
solidarity that in fact we see happening
very much right now of course we worry
about those individuals who aren't able
to participate in that connectedness
that is so natural to so many of us
right now but anyway all of that science
tells us and and I think there's really
solid agreement across the suicide
prevention sort of international
expertise which which I've been
connected with recently to agree that it
is not a foregone conclusion that we
will see suicide rates increase and in
fact the data that we have from our
wonderful colleague organizations at
crisis text line and the National
Suicide Prevention lifeline is that
while distress in the forms of anxiety
in many cases grief concerns about
isolation and economic strain that has
not translated into an increase in the
rate of suicidal crisis and you know we
again there are ways that we can
mitigate and prevent it from going there
even for people who are at risk by by
being community members family members
co-workers who are encouraging and who
are opening up dialogue so that people
can actually share some of the burden
that they're feeling that is therapeutic
in and of itself I'm relieved to hear
that and the the idea of societies sort
of coming together right now I think is
one that that I personally feel like you
know we open our windows and at 6:00
p.m. and clap for health care workers
and I know and in Italy people have been
singing out their windows and it does
feel like there's this this moment that
brings people together where I'm just
checking on neighbors in a way that I
wouldn't maybe otherwise so so that's
great to hear that a vulnerable
population is actually maybe not so
vulnerable after all Cindy do you have a
next question for um yeah dr. Duckworth
I wanted to ask this of you of viewer
wanted to ask you specifically are there
any online support groups run by Nami
that would work on the national level
because this viewers local affiliate has
shut down and they don't have the
staffing to move the activities online
so just wondering what resources are
available to someone like that
it's an excellent question and we're
gonna work to jumpstart the affiliates
and their financial situation we're
running virtual walks almost all the
Nami walks which our great fundraisers
had to be cancelled because of what we
call physical distancing we like
physical distancing and social
connection not social distancing so
first of all the affiliates may get
jump-started either through the loans or
through Nami walks that will be virtual
and creative the Nami kovat 19 guide
which has one hundred and fifty thousand
downloads has a list of resources some
of Tommy's programming is online Nami
basics is online this is a program for
parents with young children who have
mental health phoner abilities that
doubt those downloads have exploded Nami
is actively working to put more
programming online and we're running a
webinar in a few weeks on how peers are
supporting each other so we'll be
featuring people with lived experience
of bipolar disorder and schizophrenia
what they're doing in their local areas
or affiliates it's an excellent question
and I had one other question
for either of you really about you know
one of the most tragic elements of this
crisis being that people are losing
loved ones and they are not able to have
funerals and people are grieving alone
essentially and I was just wondering
given that's pretty unprecedented what
the sort of guidelines are for kind of
managing through that for the people who
look find themselves in that horrifying
situation yeah I can take at least a
piece of that it is just that is I think
you've identified one of the most
unusual and sort of uniquely horrifying
specific issues right now related to the
contagion of the virus itself and and
the impact also then on the healthcare
workers and other workers who are
involved during those moments of either
illness or as the person is passing and
the family members are not able to
even come in contact with them I mean
this is this is unprecedented in that at
least at the scale that we're dealing
with and you know I would just this is
not a simple matter there are no simple
solutions here but I think some of the
basics still apply which are that if so
for example if you know someone who is
in that situation do not assume that
because you haven't had that personal
experience you don't have any place in
providing comfort or support whether
their loved one is sick or has passed
that grief that and and traumatic
experience that their that they're
experiencing can be buoyed by the love
and care and compassion of people around
them so never ever assume that you'll
you shouldn't you know reach out to them
because you don't know what to say or
you don't have the language right just
reach out just be there for them in the
same ways that you would for your
community members when any type of
illness or death occurs I think what can
I'm going to ask one final question and
then we're gonna wrap this session and
we'll transition to our open Town Hall
with all four of our guests can I want
to ask you one kind of related topic to
this is drug and alcohol in a moment
like this and you know just from a
personal level like alcohol is something
that you know I'm kind of using to cook
just to have a drink at the end of the
day and be like okay this is this has
been a stressful day but you know what
what kind of numbers or calls for help
are you seeing from people who are
having substance abuse issues during
this time substance use disorder is a
common code traveler with serious mental
illness and to get back to dr. Lucia's
point earlier the government's loosening
restrictions on access to suboxone
through telehealth which is a treatment
for opiate use disorder for methadone
which is another treatment for opiate
use disorder one of the positives we
have here is that a a and NA and smart
recovery already had an online
portfolio before this began so I think
the challenge is you have a new
additional stress in your life which is
this they may be more stress it may be
your employment situation and I think re
upping your supports whether that's a
sponsor whether it's someone through
Nami who understands the co-occurring
nature of your life and what works for
you but I think this is a good time to
inventory it I think if you don't have
this vulnerability you know what you
described Joel having a beer at the end
of the day if that's never been a
vulnerability for you if your liver
enzymes are fine I don't think we have
to go to prohibition during a time of
stress but I think for a lot of people
these are vulnerabilities and can be
very maladaptive coping strategies there
are a lot of resources and a lot of
support for people online continue do
you have any other questions that we
double more minutes just I'm not I was
curious if for people with substance
abuse disorder if some of this the
emergency rooms being totally now
dedicated to Kove it at all changes what
happens for people in a sort of overdose
and detox situation where people are
supposed to go or where you might take a
loved one in that situation emergency
rooms are quiet right now across America
so my colleagues who work in emergency
room say you know where the psychiatric
vulnerabilities and the detoxes are
happening are happening off-camera to us
we are not seeing them this of course
raises all the local patchwork
challenges of do you have access to
mobile crisis in your health plan or
your zip code American doesn't have a
coherent national health system it has a
patchwork of benefits and opportunities
depending on where you live and what
where you get your health plan from so
figure out do you have mobile crisis
because you may not want to go to the
urgency room for a psychiatric Balmer
ability you can be detoxed at home from
things like opiates
it is not life-threatening it can be
life-threatening the detox from alcohol
so you need to work with your primary
care provider and like emergency rooms
many primary care providers are not
overwhelmed right now all the routine
physicals all the routine procedures all
the dermatologically knees are doing
have been postponed so your primary care
doctor is in a very good position to
help you think about how to manage your
vulnerability with addiction substance
use disorder or with a mental health
crisis so we use this moment we're gonna
bring in our previous cute gasp and
we'll have on all six of us together and
this last session with everyone is
really a chance for us to ask questions
from our viewers so if you haven't posed
a question please do so you can tweet at
that hashtag VW town call and you know
these questions are all coming from
people who have been watching and who
want to ask you guys question
Cynthia do you have one that you'd like
to start us off with yeah I'm looking
through the questions right now what
advice would you give to kids in the
time of lockdown I've heard some
interesting thoughts about kids you know
being used to being connected
technologically but this is you know
taking a lot away from them giving them
no social interaction at all so just
curious what you recommend for for kids
and I guess parent children as well keep
an eye on their mental health and also
you know mental health good mental
health habit this time well I can start
us off because we think a lot about the
parent community and of course kids are
in different places have different
vulnerabilities depending on the age of
your kids but I'll say a couple things
and then and then let my colleagues
chime in that as a parent keeping your
own well-being and your own mental
health as grounded during this time
might be the best thing you can do for
the the sort of secondary including your
kids if they see you able to laugh and
connect with them and tell stories over
the dinner table and check in with each
other that is extremely reassuring to to
the children in our lives and I think
the second thing I would say is they may
have concerns about what is going on and
again depending on the age of the child
I don't think it's necessary to
overwhelm them with every latest bit on
the CDC website about this but really
just respond to their questions and
provide them with a lot of sense of
reassurance that you know there is a lot
of uncertainty right now we are being
safe as a family because we're following
all of the recommendations and we're
going to get through this really
confirming a sense of optimism and hope
is very helpful of course for all of us
but particularly for children and I
think if you have children that already
have a vulnerability childhood OCD or a
history of trauma the national child
trauma trauma stress Network has great
resources for how to think about what
could be a retrim attic experience for
children
this question comes from a viewer Katie
you asked assuming this increases demand
for therapies to what degrees you see
cost for therapy rising and how can
those who can't afford to spend much on
therapy come on top of this economic
challenge one of the things we've tried
to do that maybe I'll maybe I'll direct
that one to you yeah and sorry I jumped
right in one of the things we've tried
to do at brightside prior to this crisis
was to provide an affordable easy and
quick way for people to get both therapy
online but also access to psychiatry and
psychiatric meds delivered delivered to
their doorstep so cost we knew was an
issue going into this because the
initial session is so out of reach for
so many people and so bright side along
with I think other online providers can
provide a very cost-effective way for
people to get into treatment if they
haven't previously had treatment or
perhaps bridge their treatment in this
time when they need to get treatment
from the comfort of their home I've also
seen a lot of movement from insurers
both we've expanded our breath with
insurers but they've really been looking
to step up and expand the ability to
promote access and they've all done a
lot of work so whereby it was probably
very very difficult to find the provider
and network it's worth trying now so
reached out for those you have that
ability to your insurance provider and
see if they can help you I am I have a
question and and can I'll go to you with
this one is I'm a manager in the midst
of this what kind of questions should I
be asking my employees as we as they
navigate their own mental mental health
issues well I think in general in an
employer role you want to touch base
with them let them know you're
supportive of them but not necessarily
inquire about their mental health
vulnerabilities right if they want to
that is attending to people's well-being
as part of their benefit package but I
think not allowing your employees to be
isolated connect with them touch base
with them because some people will not
necessarily be forthcoming with human
connection through their own employer
and I just I'm just throwing it out
there because I thought that was a
really cool idea because sometimes you
know you have your friend but there are
people who might be more reserved and
they might dog yeah you might not
necessarily think that you need to reach
out so it's a cool idea that one it was
like a health group who is the health
care provider we're doing that everyone
had someone to talk I had a fight you
talk a little bit about hoping that the
government he's sort of more open stance
towards health what about the state
licensing changes that are going on that
are making it possible for providers who
work in different states because I know
there's some counties in America that
don't have many countries America that
don't have a big fire etcetera so I'm
just wondering if there's any effort to
lobby the government school or see
Berman's to continue to liberalize state
licensing regulations yeah we're seeing
that happen again related to Co vid that
the states that have declared a state of
emergency many of them that have they
have translated that into lifting the
usual restrictions in terms of the
practice of in particularly telehealth
across state lines and you know I'll let
my colleagues who are much more expert
in the telehealth world speak to the the
intricacies of that from the from the
top line view I would say that at AF SP
our policy team is looking for those
opportunities both at the federal and
the state level to make sure that we
don't go backwards after the corona
virus pandemic ends you go ahead go
ahead no apologize it never made a lot
of sense that I sitting in New York
can't see someone in New Jersey via
telehealth that they can come to my
office and see me so now is the
inflection point to change what really
has been an artifact of an earlier time
and there's been just hasn't been enough
momentum to change it we've been trying
as I'm sure many others with us here
today and around the country have been
trying but as Christine said it's really
about not going back and using this as
an opportunity to bring us to probably
where we should have been before and not
I don't look at it as this needs to
happen because of where we are now this
should have happened probably a couple
of years ago now tell us obviously what
we have right now and it's wonderful in
helping many people in many ways but are
there any limitations are there any
things that the provider may be using
the telehealth platform it's hard to do
X Y or Z or the follow up can be hard
hey are there any what are those I think
the sort of good practice of
telemedicine is predicated on having the
right tools so there are a lot of health
systems right now that are trying to
piece together telehealth solutions by
Scotch taping things together that you
know it can work
for sure it can work but if you have a
great set of tools like the ones we've
built a bread side prior the this crisis
it just is a seamless process and
particularly in mental health we're able
to deliver care that's not just at par
with what's happening in the community
but actually potentially care that
exceeds what happens in the community
because we have built so many remote
patient monitoring tools so we know how
you're doing in between visits we know
how the patients are doing in between
telehealth visits and can actually
measure those changes continuously and
you know having those tools at our
disposal makes telehealth a very very
very powerful tool for mental health so
as we reach the end of our of our time I
just want to do a little bit of a round
robin and give give people an actionable
piece of advice that they can take away
from you and apply to their life and
hopefully benefit from in this time Ken
I'm gonna start with you where do you
feel is a number-one takeaway you want
people to have right now never worry
alone Nami org the Nami helpline the 650
affiliates across the nation can help
you problems aisle
your own vulnerability or someone you
love dr. yeh sure and I'll gear this
more towards the workplace and kind of
business community for whom maybe the
topic of mental health hasn't
necessarily been top of mind although
that has been changing in the last
couple years just remember that the
brain is part of our body and when we
take care of our health whether it's the
weather our lead in is physical health
concern or a mental health concerns
we're taking care of our overall health
so protecting your brain and protecting
your mental health is going to actually
lead to better physical health outcomes
and all of that accrues to a workplace
where the culture is able to handle
health issues in the most just and
protected way both for the employee as
well as for the bottom line of the
company and and I would just say the one
takeaway in terms of actionable strategy
is
if you can learn to incorporate some
language into your daily practices even
in the workplace where you make it
abundantly evident that you are a safe
and trustworthy place and person to for
your staff to be able to bring up their
concerns you know it's not a matter of
intruding on their health issues but
it's it's creating a platform where
should they want to discuss those with
you that that they can trust that this
will be a safe environment for them to
do that I think that creates the best
outcomes for all involved meaning your
closing time yeah I agree so much with
what dr. Madea said about you know the
brain being part of the body and that
mental health not doesn't just
contribute to physical health but
actually helps our immune system to I
think it's really important to
underscore that right now that having a
you know positive mental health tools
will actually bolster your immune system
during this time we are we are happy to
help at bright side you can take an
assessment on our website you can get
care within 48 48 hours from the comfort
of your home be that access to
medication to a psychiatrist to to
therapy tools and a therapist so please
visit our website if you or a loved one
is suffering right now and we can help
so don't isolate paradoxically this is a
time when we can strengthen connections
with our loved ones with our friends
reconnect with people in our busy worlds
of not calling people and not
communicating is this is probably the
best time to take advantage of that and
build on that and for some of you if it
gets too tough there a therapist whether
it's us or others who are there for when
that's not enough for you that's great
Cynthia do you have mental health is a
topic that I've encouraged you to be
writing about in the magazines over the
last year do you have a closing thought
that you'd like to provide well I think
one thing that's been in my mind is
we've sort of already started to go
through stages of trying to adjust to
this they're getting used to it and then
trying to figure out how long this goes
and what happens next and so I mean I
would encourage people to continue to
reach out to us but their stories
because we're still continuing to cover
this and we know that they're gonna be
many legs to this and it's going to
change as if prolong so we're here and
we want to write more about it we want
to hear from all of you so I throw that
out there just to say that we're not
done covering this be written about it
absolutely
all right well to each of you I just
want to say thank you for joining this
Business Week Town Hall this is actually
the first one of these we've done but it
won't be the last we want to hear more
from you about the topics that you'd
like to hear about and we look forward
to doing them with greater frequency
again just thank you to all of you and
what you get back from doing your
important jobs and the Banting moment
and just thank you for all the good work
that you're doing thank you